joining me on the mercedes-benz vans
phone line is none other than the kansas
city chiefs quarterback getting set for
a big monday night football game to wrap
up week eight that beckons over the
steering wheel of the longest regular
season ever he is patrick mahomes how
are you patrick
i'm doing good how are you how you been
i am good yeah normally that that's just
a way i start uh conversations how are
you doing but this is a like legitimate
question how are you doing patrick i'm
good man uh you know uh coming off a
tough loss there in tennessee but uh
excited for the challenge of getting to
play on monday night football so uh uh
physically i'm doing good and i'm i'm
excited to get back after it this week
okay yeah cause i'll be honest with you
i i actually you know um got off the
couch when i saw the hit that you took
like i legitimately stood up concerned
for your well-being uh how is that like
have you watched that back on film yet
yeah i saw it on film it definitely
looked pretty bad it kind of just kind
of
shocked me there for a second but i felt
i felt fine the whole entire time i kind
of want to take my time getting to the
sideline and
trust me they've put me through about a
million protocols already so uh
everything's good to go and i'm ready to
get back after i'm just wondering what
it's like to watch that back for
yourself that that would be disturbing
to me that's what i'm saying
oh no yeah it was uh it didn't look
great i think my mom was more worried
than anybody
okay so once you text your mom
everything's all good now you're ready
for the giants uh so patrick i'll just
jump right into it um what i'll just
give you the floor on what do you think
is uh wrong with the team right now and
the fact that we're not used to seeing
you guys play the way that you've played
through the first seven weeks of this
season
yeah i mean to me i don't know if it's
necessarily
wrong but i think it's just execution i
mean uh i believe that we have the guys
we have the players we have the coaches
um to do whatever we really want um but
um i think that's how we execute and in
the nfl if you don't execute uh you lose
football games um and uh you've seen
that from us when we play good um i
think we can play uh with anybody um but
uh
when we when we don't execute and when
we don't have uh great games and we
don't play to the way that our uh that
we've been coached into our ability uh
we lose
um and uh you've seen that over this
season is we've had highs but we've had
lows um and so um it's how we correct
those how we get better and i'm excited
just to kind of get back after it how do
you approach it i mean
you're you're going through easily the
longest stretch of adversity of your
professional playing career uh how are
you handling the first sort of long
stretch of what you say flowers roses
there's no flowers and roses and what
did you say this past year yeah yeah no
it was uh yeah i have to you have to
respond to it i think that's the biggest
thing if you look at all the
uh the great teams um they always have
dealt with uh spurts of that adversity
um we're definitely dealing with one
that's longer than we wanted uh
something that we didn't expect but how
are we going to respond how are we going
to be better um be better because of it
um i think is as huge and uh
we get a great chance on monday night
to really show that we can get this
thing back on track against a really
good football team so i'm excited for it
i think the guys in this locker room are
excited for the challenge and hopefully
when we look back on this uh this spurt
of adverse that we have we can show that
that was the reason why we became the
team that we wanted to become patrick
mahomes here on the rich eisen show in
advance of monday night football between
the chiefs and the giants that comes up
in just a matter of days so um if you
don't mind i'm gonna throw a couple um
theories out there that is being bandied
about in the nfl media world that may or
may not have passed your ear gate to use
a michael irvin phrase that i pick up on
game day morning uh to see if if there's
any legitimacy to it uh the fact that
you're three and four is uh ascribed to
perhaps you've been figured out
offensively by the rest of the league
how do you respond to that patrick yes
yeah i mean uh
i feel like we we still done a lot of
great things offensively uh we obviously
didn't have the game that we wanted to
have this last week um but uh i think if
we get these guys get to get the things
rolling we execute and we cut the
turnovers out i think this offense can
still be pretty special especially when
you have coach reed uh coach reed
coaching it i don't think he's been
figured out too many times another one
is that you're trying personally to do
too much that whatever is
uh whatever adversity is hitting your
team um maybe defensively or
elsewhere on the field you personally
patrick mahomes are trying to get that
19 point touchdown or something like
that how do you yeah i i don't i don't
it's nothing to do i think there is
moments where i am trying to do too much
but i think it's nothing to do with any
other guys on the on the team uh offense
defense or special teams i think it's
just me wanting to win i mean i want to
win i think more than pretty much
everybody and i try to do whatever i can
to put our team in the best positions to
win but there's times where i where the
way that i've done the turnovers that
i've created uh the fumbles the
interceptions have hurt the team in a
more than a way that i didn't intend to
happen so uh me kind of getting back to
my fundamentals i think will be
extremely important um for us to have
success this season do you beat yourself
up mentally when those when that happens
what's your what what goes between your
temples patrick if you don't mind me
prying on that yeah i mean i'm
definitely disappointed uh after the
moment uh it happens in the game but i
think i have the mindset of kind of just
washington moving on to the next play
um i'll never be discouraged by
uh turnovers or anything like that as
long as i can find a way to make them
better and find a way to win the
football games um so obviously after the
games like last this last one we lost
i'm definitely
uh upset after the game but uh we're
already back at it now i mean we're back
at it trying to find a way to beat the
meet the new york giants um and we know
it's gonna take our best effort and i
can't dwell on losing to the tennessee
titans i gotta kind of focus on the next
week uh playing the new york giants okay
um and the last theory patrick mahomes
is that after two years of afc
championship
uh winning football including one year
where you win the super bowl all those
long seasons and
now the target on your back keeps
getting hung every week after week
everybody's giving you their best shots
that there's a super bowl or uh
long-term hangover that's finally
hanging over this team what do you think
about that one
yeah i mean i don't i don't think so i
don't know i don't even really know what
that means uh i mean if you whenever
you're in the super bowl uh you want to
get back i mean
winning one and and losing one i mean i
think losing one maybe even more that
you want to find a way to get back to
that game
um
we we've kind of had that target on our
back for a last couple years now i i
mean to me it's a great thing to have
you get the best shot from every single
team um so you get to see really where
you're at every single week um and it
prepares you for the runs uh and the
playoffs or prepares you for the runs at
the end of the season
um and so uh i'm excited for the
challenge i mean when you look back at
some of the great moments of great teams
they've went through adversity and so uh
i'm excited for the challenge of it to
try to see how we respond and see if we
can make this a memorable season that uh
a lot of people get to talk about about
how we didn't start the way we wanted to
and we kind of became who we wanted to
become best uh a couple minutes left
here with patrick mahomes here on the
rich eisen show if you could wave a wand
patrick i make you commissioner of the
nfl what what change do you make what do
you do
i could wave a while i i i don't even
know uh what do you think rule change
you got a rule change that you don't
like what do you think i would say
uh
if i had to make a rule change maybe i
don't know maybe give us another bye
week or something like that i think the
guys would like that okay an extra bye
week off is that uh a new father talking
is that uh what that's about
that might be my might be getting a
little older now i understand how
talking to some of these vet guys i'm
sure they would appreciate it okay how
is fatherhood treating you i've never
been able to ask you that question
because i haven't spoken it since you've
had your your baby girl uh how's father
how are you balancing fatherhood and
professional football and everything
else in your life yeah it's been amazing
honestly uh to be able to go home um and
see that little girl every single day i
mean it it truly is a an awesome feeling
and uh we're almost crawling now we've
gotten teeth okay uh she's saying ah
which to me it's like really close to
dada okay britney says it's really close
to mama so uh we're
kind of battling that one out too i'm
saying dada and every third third word
of my sentences is that right
how's your k how's your cadence on that
you're getting yeah i'm pretty good at
it i've kind of figured it out you know
i'm getting it to just enough where it
kind of just sits there just so when she
says it i i have that satisfaction okay
very good uh at least as long as she's
not saying uh offered to stay andy first
right that that would be no no hopefully
not there's hopefully not but uh yeah
we're working on it we're getting there
it gets close you gotta you gotta get it
there okay cool um and then last one for
you patrick i don't know if you're if
you saw this um with uh with tom brady
his 600th
career touchdown pass was given away by
his receiver to a fan did you see that
one this past weekend i did see that
that was uh it's amazing to even get to
600 touchdowns first off yes you can't
get past that i mean
uh you got to play for a long time and
have a lot of success and uh he for sure
is the definition of that and uh i mean
mike mike evans you know that's just a
signature thing giving out the football
the fan got pretty got some pretty good
gifts i would say in return yes um did
you hear that tom gave him a bitcoin did
you hear that one patrick i i saw it
last night on the manning cast a little
bit i saw them talking i saw that uh it
came out with he got a bitcoin i'm tom's
handing them out i'll take one too yeah
i know i mean i'm imagining um that by
the time knock on wood you have an
opportunity to knock on that 600
touchdown uh career passing uh touchdown
door
bitcoin is gonna be more than 70 grand i
think right so oh that's the hope you
know uh i i hope luckily my friends got
me in a little bit earlier but uh i'm
hoping that it rises up there so you
know like 150 200 yeah that's what i'm
saying is that maybe you get one now
just in case a receiver who's currently
maybe not yet born
uh hands that touchdown pass away to a
fan sitting in the front row an
arrowhead or something like that so you
could get that out of the way now yeah
actually i actually told chad henny his
son his son's a quarterback so
um maybe when he's up there playing with
me yeah um and uh we have a reverse
double quarterback pass and i throw it
to him i like it he can uh i'll get
something that that he can give away for
it i like it patrick see that's what
you're looking over the steering wheel
and you're very positive as i've as
we've heard throughout this entire
interview and i guess that's the way i
want to i want to wrap it up is how how
come you're so positive what what
message do you want to give to chiefs
fans who are i think you're aware
freaking out right now with your team
being with you yeah no i think um what
my message i have is we have the people
we have the players we understand what
it takes and it's about us putting in
the work every single day um i think
when you have guys like this leaders
that have been a part of this culture
for for this long now we're gonna leave
everything we have in that field every
single sunday or monday this week um and
uh i think we're gonna right the ship
and uh get back to the kansas city
chiefs football everybody's accustomed
to patrick thanks for the time greatly
appreciate it let's do this uh more
often we'll chat down the line much
appreciated as i said
i i appreciate you as well and congrats
on the saint jude's thing man oh thank
you patrick i i greatly appreciate it
you know um i'm just trying to keep up
with uh you and kelsey and the rest of
the team with uh with trying to be good
in the community you know what i mean
just trying to be doing my part that's
what it's all about thanks patrick you
take care that's patrick mahomes kansas
city chiefs quarterback right here on
the rich eisen show hey you watched all
the way to the end thanks for that watch
more right here